Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode, we are looking at health psychology. What is it? What
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨健康心理学。它是什么？它
does it involve? How do you do it? Do you get paid? And what are the differences across the UK for how the courses are set up? I am interviewing an end stage health trainee psychologist and the conversation is lively, wholesome and nourishing. We talk about grief, we talk about death, we talk about strength, we talk about wellness and of course health psychology. It is a wonderful listen and I hope you find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for listening, for watching. It's one of my key responsibilities, I feel, for this podcast to illuminate different areas of professional psychology qualifications. And
包含哪些内容？它是如何运作的？有报酬吗？英国各地在课程设置上有什么不同？我采访了一位即将结业的健康心理学实习生，对话生动、健康且充满营养。我们谈论了悲伤、死亡、力量、健康，当然还有健康心理学。这是一期非常精彩的节目，希望你能从中受益。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢大家的收听和观看。我觉得这个播客的核心职责之一，就是阐明专业心理学资格的不同领域。而
one that we haven't covered as yet, but I have been very keen to do so is health psychology. Let's dive in. I hope you find this episode as beautiful as I found it to record. I will catch you on the other side. Just want to welcome along Nicola O'Donnell to the podcast. Hi, Nicola. Hello, thank you for having me. Well, thank you so much for saying yes. I really wanted to talk to you um primarily because you're a trainee health psychologist but I know you've got so much more going on that's going to be really interesting for me to listen to and speak with you about but also of course our audience as well so before we crash into some of that could you tell us a little bit about you and kind of how you got into psychology?
我们尚未涉及，但我一直非常渴望探讨的一个领域就是健康心理学。让我们深入了解吧。希望你觉得这一集和我录制时一样精彩。我们稍后见。首先欢迎尼古拉·奥唐奈（Nicola O'Donnell）来到播客。你好，尼古拉。你好，谢谢你的邀请。非常感谢你答应参加。我之所以想和你谈谈，主要是因为你是一名健康心理学实习生，但我知道你身上还有很多其他值得我倾听和探讨的内容，这对我们的听众来说也非常有意义。所以在深入探讨之前，你能先简单介绍一下自己，以及你是如何进入心理学领域的吗？
Yes it's always such I feel like such a long journey for so many people to get into psychology and to qualify or nearly qualify as is the case for me so thinking back in preparation for today I first started sort of studying psychology in 2010 when I took it for my A-level and just fell in love with the subject and felt like for the first time in my life it was something that I was good at I was always sort of pretty average at school but when I started doing psychology thought oh actually this is something that I want to do so um I decided to go to university to study it further so in 2012 I did my undergraduate at the University of Kent um in applied psychology with clinical psychology um and I think the the sort of crunch point for me within that was I did a placement year so I did a four-year undergraduate and for the third year spent a whole year working in the NHS kind of as an assistant psychologist um within pediatrics and just absolutely loved it and solidified that this is what I want to do
是的，我觉得对很多人来说，进入心理学领域并获得资格或即将获得资格（就像我一样）是一段漫长的旅程。回想一下，为了今天的节目做准备，我最早是在 2010 年开始接触心理学的，当时我选修了 A-level 课程，并从此爱上了这门学科。我第一次感觉到自己擅长某件事，因为我在学校里一直表现平平，但当我开始学习心理学时，我心想：“哦，这确实是我想要做的事情。”于是，我决定去大学深造。2012 年，我在肯特大学（University of Kent）完成了应用心理学与临床心理学的本科课程。我认为对我来说，其中的关键转折点是我参加了实习年，我读的是四年制本科，第三年花了一整年时间在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）担任儿科助理心理学家，我非常热爱这份工作，这让我坚定了这就是我想要从事的职业。
as a job um so I mean I think I can go into more if I'm not talking too much but um I was really lucky and completely credit my placement year to the fact that I was successful in getting an assistant psychologist job immediately after my undergraduate course so I started a assistant role in CAMS so Child and Adolescent Mental Health Services and they very kindly encouraged me to do a further qualification in low intensity CBT so I was quickly in you know getting experience working with children and young people one-to-one their families offering low intensity cognitive behavior therapy particularly for things like low mood and anxiety but also working within a wider eating disorder service as well so I was really lucky to get quite a lot of hands-on experience quite quickly so for a long time I didn't know what health I didn't know that health psychology was a thing I didn't know that it
所以我认为，如果我没说太多废话的话，我可以再多讲一点。我非常幸运，完全归功于我的实习年，让我在本科毕业后立即成功获得了一份助理心理学家的工作。我开始在儿童和青少年心理健康服务中心（CAMHS）担任助理职位。他们非常友善地鼓励我进一步考取低强度认知行为疗法（CBT）的资格。所以我很快就开始积累经验，与儿童、青少年及其家庭进行一对一的工作，提供针对低落情绪和焦虑等问题的低强度认知行为疗法，同时也参与了更广泛的饮食失调服务。所以我很幸运，很快就获得了大量的实践经验。很长一段时间里，我并不知道健康心理学是什么，也不知道它
existed I always knew that I was interested in working psychologically in health settings. But I thought that clinical psychology would be the only way to do that. And I actually applied for clinical psychology doctorate on three occasions and was offered interviews and twice a reserve place that never came through to joining a course, which I found really, really hard at the time. But I'm very grateful now that it kind of led me in a different direction in discovering what health psychology is and how to go about becoming a health psychologist, which I'm sure we'll talk about today. So I enrolled on my master's in 2020 so COVID did my whole master's at UCL but from home which was challenging but also gave me something to do I suppose during lockdown and then later enrolled
的存在。我一直知道自己对在医疗环境中进行心理工作很感兴趣，但我以为临床心理学是实现这一目标的唯一途径。我实际上申请过三次临床心理学博士课程，也获得过面试机会，还有两次进入了候补名单，但最终都没能进入课程，这在当时让我感到非常痛苦。但现在我很感激，因为它引导我走向了另一个方向，让我发现了什么是健康心理学，以及如何成为一名健康心理学家，我相信我们今天会谈到这一点。所以我于 2020 年注册了硕士课程，因为疫情的原因，我在伦敦大学学院（UCL）完成了全部硕士学业，虽然是在家里完成的，很有挑战性，但也让我在封锁期间有事可做。后来，我于 2022 年注册了
on my final stage of training stage two in 2022 which I will qualify from hopefully next month so all all coming to an end very soon haven't even mentioned the PhD in that but we'll come back to the PhD in a moment so um thank you so much that's really really interesting and like as you talk I'm like you have traveled quite a lot for your career haven't you because I know just before we hit record you're like I've just moved from Suffolk and now I'm actually up north and you know there's been some other um you know you said you're I think you said your undergrad was Kent so there's been there's been a lot of movement and that is not uncommon in the psychology field as well but just to follow
我的最后阶段培训（第二阶段），希望下个月就能结业。所以一切都快要结束了。还没提到博士学位，但我们稍后再谈。非常感谢，这真的非常有趣。听你这么说，我觉得你的职业生涯走过不少地方，对吧？因为我知道在录音前你提到刚从萨福克郡搬过来，现在住在北部，而且你还说你的本科是在肯特读的。所以你确实经历了很多变动，这在心理学领域并不罕见。但我想接着
up on what you said about your um ucl distance learning so that's for your health psychology professional qualifications it starts as a master's and then it sounds like there's an additional bit could you tell us about that and how how that extra bit works do some people not choose to do that I presume that's so you can go on and be registered as a practitioner psychologist with the HCPC that's why you do the extra bit is it? Yeah so in order to practice as a health psychologist you have to do both what's known as stage one and stage two and I'm really passionate about explaining this in hopefully an accessible way because I think compared to lots of other psychology training routes health psychology is really confusing you have to do a lot of digging around to find out
你刚才提到的关于伦敦大学学院（UCL）远程学习的话题。那是为了你的健康心理学专业资格吗？它从硕士开始，听起来还有一个额外的部分。你能告诉我们关于那部分的内容以及它是如何运作的吗？有些人会选择不参加吗？我猜那是为了让你能够继续注册成为英国健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）的执业心理学家，所以才需要完成那额外部分，是吗？是的，为了作为健康心理学家执业，你必须完成所谓的“第一阶段”和“第二阶段”。我非常热衷于以一种易于理解的方式来解释这一点，因为我认为与其他许多心理学培训途径相比，健康心理学真的非常令人困惑，你必须进行大量的挖掘才能弄清楚
how you actually enroll to become a health psychologist and um it's something that I'm asked on a weekly basis how does it all work and how do I go about doing it so from the beginning you obviously have to do an undergraduate in psychology which you would do for all routes of um further psychology training um and helpful to have some experience working clinically as well um in order to make sure firstly that you enjoy the subject but also to give you some real life real real world experience of what a psychologist does and imply applying some of those theoretical concepts that you spend so long learning about into sort of real life and working with real people and then the masters that I mentioned is the stage one of doctoral training so this is
你到底该如何注册成为一名健康心理学家。这是我每周都会被问到的问题：它是如何运作的？我该怎么做？从一开始，你显然必须拥有心理学本科学位，这是所有进一步心理学培训途径的必经之路。拥有一些临床工作经验也很有帮助，首先是为了确保你确实喜欢这门学科，其次是为了让你获得一些真实的、现实世界中心理学家工作经验，并将你花费大量时间学习的理论概念应用到现实生活中，与真实的人打交道。然后我提到的硕士学位是博士培训的第一阶段，所以这
usually a year full-time and it's really important that everyone who wants to become a health psychologist does this because it gives you that broad grounding of major health psychology theories and concepts and that is accredited by the bps the british psychological society just like an undergraduate usually would have been and some people stop there some people go on and do lots of varied and interesting things from that master's but if you want to practice as a qualified health psychologist you need to do what's known as stage two and this is where it gets a bit complicated because there's lots of different ways that you can do that and I'll obviously speak more about the way that I've done it but I'll give a brief overview of the different ways you can do it because I think this is the thing that people find most confusing so the first option is doing a doctorate in health
通常是一年的全日制课程。对于所有想成为健康心理学家的人来说，完成这一阶段非常重要，因为它为你提供了主要的健康心理学理论和概念的广泛基础。这就像本科课程一样，是由英国心理学会（BPS）认证的。有些人到此为止，有些人从硕士毕业后去做了许多多样且有趣的事情。但如果你想作为一名合格的健康心理学家执业，你需要完成所谓的“第二阶段”。这部分就变得有点复杂了，因为有很多不同的方式可以完成它。我显然会更多地谈论我所采用的方式，但我会简要概述一下其他方式，因为我认为这是人们觉得最困惑的地方。第一种选择是在大学攻读健康
psychology at a university I think quite like clinical psychology you have a structured training program you have a cohort of peers and you access your training in this way I did not do that the second option is the what's known as the independent route and that takes a minimum of two years and instead of being attached to a course and a university you're attached to a supervisor under the BPS and you have two years at least of structured and supervised practice in order to meet the health psychology competencies which are professional practice, consultancy, psychological interventions, research and teaching and training and many people like me do this alongside an academic PhD so that you get a dual qualification and can utilize your PhD to fulfill the stage two research
心理学博士学位。我想这和临床心理学很像，你有一个结构化的培训项目，有一群同伴，并以这种方式获得培训。我没有走这条路。第二种选择是所谓的“独立途径”，至少需要两年时间。你不是依附于某个课程或大学，而是依附于英国心理学会（BPS）下的一名导师。你至少需要两年的结构化和受监督的实践，以达到健康心理学的胜任力要求，即专业实践、咨询、心理干预、研究以及教学与培训。许多像我这样的人会将其与学术博士学位（PhD）结合起来，这样你就可以获得双重资格，并利用你的博士研究来满足第二阶段的研究
competency but equally you can do just just the stage two on its own without the PhD but you I suppose it's worth knowing that you can't use the title of doctor if you haven't done the PhD with that independent route I see that's what I did that is yeah is quite confusing and that's not even all the options there's another two so go for it tell me the other two I'm sorry go for it so Health Education England as of two years ago have a funded program which I suppose is the draw because the others are self-funded which is aiming to apply health behavior change to NHS workforce redesign so I think there's seven funded places in England for that so that's the relatively new route and then there's seven funded places in England for that. So that's the relatively new route.
胜任力要求。但同样，你也可以只完成第二阶段而不攻读博士学位。不过，值得注意的是，如果你没有通过独立途径获得博士学位，你就不能使用“博士”这个头衔。我明白了，原来是这样。这确实很令人困惑，而且这还不是全部选项，还有另外两种。请继续，告诉我另外两种。抱歉，请继续。好的，英国健康教育局（Health Education England）在两年前推出了一个资助项目，我想这正是吸引人的地方，因为其他途径都是自费的。该项目旨在将健康行为改变应用于 NHS 的劳动力重组。我想在英格兰有七个资助名额，所以这是一个相对较新的途径。
And then there's an NHS. Do you mean seven funded courses or literally seven funded places for the whole of England? Seven people. Yeah. Oh, my days. That's not a lot, is it? Yeah. Not a lot.
还有一个 NHS 的项目。你是说七个资助课程，还是整个英格兰只有七个资助名额？七个人。天哪，这可不多，对吧？是的，确实不多。
So I think. Are they remote? Are they in person? Or are they attached to one particular university? So they're attached to an individual area within or region within England. So again, I won't speak too much to it, because I'm not doing this route. But my understanding is that each trainee is allocated to an area like the east of England and then they do their work within that particular area focusing on workforce redesign within the NHS so not many people are funded to do that but I think it is a growing and a growing way to become a health psychologist and one that hopefully will
所以我想。它们是远程的吗？是线下的吗？还是附属于某所特定的大学？它们附属于英格兰境内的某个特定区域或地区。同样，我不会谈论太多，因为我没有走这条路。但据我了解，每位实习生都被分配到一个区域，比如英格兰东部，然后他们在该特定区域内工作，专注于 NHS 内部的劳动力重组。所以没有多少人能获得资助，但我认为这是一种正在增长的成为健康心理学家的方式，希望未来能
gain more and more funding as well. But they're flying solo then so they haven't got someone else living locally because there's seven across England so they might they're probably living in very different areas of the country yeah although I do think from knowing people that are on that training route that they have a really strong and supportive network between them but yeah geographically very spread apart um and then the last route's NHS Scotland which their Scotland seem to be so far ahead in health psychology they've been offering funded training for years and that is very similar to clinical psychology in the way that you're employed under the nhs offering um sort of health psychology services as a trainee so lots of different ways that you can go about
获得越来越多的资金支持。但他们是单打独斗，因为全英格兰只有七个人，所以他们可能住在全国各地。是的，虽然据我所知，那些参加该培训途径的人之间有着非常强大和相互支持的网络，但在地理上确实非常分散。最后一种途径是苏格兰 NHS。苏格兰在健康心理学方面似乎遥遥领先，他们多年来一直提供资助培训。这与临床心理学非常相似，你受雇于 NHS，作为实习生提供健康心理学服务。所以有很多不同的方式可以让你
becoming a health psychologist and not always amazing no but actually really really important and it sounds like this episode is so overdue, because actually, if you're getting asked that a lot, I didn't know this stuff like, you know, and I'm another professional psychologist. um it's self-funded does that mean that you are having to work does that mean that you're eligible to claim kind of um student support finance all of that just or do you just need to be you know hoping that you've got an employer who'll pay or you know generous aunt who you know how does it how does it come about how does it come together? Yeah and I think that's another thing that is really unclear for a lot of people so as I mentioned some of the routes are funded so that isn't something that those trainees have to consider for people on the doctorate courses you are able to apply for postdoctoral loans and speaking to a friend doing that yesterday she said at the moment you're able to apply for postdoctoral loans. And speaking to a friend doing that yesterday,
成为一名健康心理学家。这并不总是那么容易，但实际上非常重要。听起来这一集的内容早就该做了，因为如果你经常被问到这些问题，我作为另一位专业心理学家，竟然也不知道这些。它是自费的，这意味着你必须工作吗？这意味着你有资格申请学生资助吗？还是说你只需要希望有一位愿意为你买单的雇主，或者有一位慷慨的阿姨？这一切是怎么实现的？是的，我认为这是很多人不清楚的另一点。正如我提到的，有些途径是有资助的，所以那些实习生不需要考虑这些。对于参加博士课程的人，你可以申请博士后贷款。昨天我和一位正在读博的朋友聊天，她说目前你可以申请博士后贷款。
she said at the moment, you're able to claim I think about 28,000 pounds across the course of your doctorate to help live and work and pay for the course. And the independent route is self-funded. So that's what I've done. I think it's always a struggle advising people on this because I feel like I've got quite a unique situation when it came to funding. And it isn't a particularly cheerful situation, but essentially, very sadly, my dad died in 2020 and that enabled me to pay for my training um but I also work as a researcher and have done throughout my course
她说目前，你可以在整个博士课程期间申请大约 28,000 英镑的贷款，以帮助生活、工作和支付学费。而独立途径是自费的。这就是我所做的。我觉得在建议人们时总是很纠结，因为我觉得自己在资金方面的情况相当特殊。这并不是一个特别令人愉快的情况，但本质上，非常遗憾的是，我父亲在 2020 年去世了，这使我能够支付我的培训费用。但我同时也担任研究员，并在整个课程期间一直这样做，
to top the top up my living expenses um alongside my PhD stipend that I have as well so I kind of have juggled a lot of different things in order to make it work over the last few years which isn't easy but it is doable. Yeah I'm so sorry to hear about your dad I lost my dad in 2017 and it's not easy you know we're young women you're even younger than me. It isn't easy, you know, and especially I think losing someone at that time of the pandemic, it's really, really tricky. I, like you, received some inheritance from my father, which meant that I was able to pay for my EMDR training.
以补贴我的生活开支，再加上我作为博士生获得的津贴。所以过去几年里，我为了让这一切顺利进行，平衡了很多不同的事情，这并不容易，但确实是可行的。是的，听到你父亲的消息我很难过。我在 2017 年失去了父亲，这并不容易。你知道，我们都是年轻女性，你比我还要年轻。这真的不容易，尤其是考虑到在疫情期间失去亲人，这真的非常棘手。像你一样，我也从父亲那里继承了一些遗产，这让我能够支付我的 EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）培训费用。
And so I feel like every kind of trauma intervention, every time I'm on TV doing anything trauma related, you know, any client work, my dad's with me. And I really, really like that, because he'd always been so supportive of my career, you know, he always wanted to hear what I was up to, and obviously not disclosing clinical information, but he was always my fiercest, you know, supporter. And so, you know, I hope that you have that experience. And I hope that you still have that felt sense of your dad throughout your studies and you know I think when you qualify after all of this time it's going to be even more emotional you're suddenly in a position where you're able to get paid in one job to do one job
所以我觉得每一次创伤干预，每一次我在电视上做任何与创伤相关的事情，或者进行任何客户工作时，我父亲都与我同在。我真的很喜欢这种感觉，因为他一直非常支持我的事业。他总是想听听我在做什么，当然我不会透露临床信息，但他一直是我最坚定的支持者。所以，我希望你也有同样的经历。我希望你在整个学习过程中依然能感受到父亲的存在。我想当你经过这段时间最终获得资格时，那会更加感人。你突然能够通过一份工作获得报酬，不再有学术作业，不再有论文，不再有所有这些不同的事情。我觉得你会突然意识到这一点，你会大哭一场，那将是一个非常特别、混乱的时刻，但你有很多值得骄傲的地方。
and suddenly all you know you don't have academic assignments you don't have thesis you don't have you know all these different things I just feel like you're gonna just there'll be a realization and you'll have a really good cry and you'll just be a very special messy time but you know so much to be proud of yeah no I think I don't know I think I won't know what to do with myself um and yeah I'm really sorry to hear about your dad as well because it is such a hugely difficult thing I think whatever age you are but I think particularly I was only 25 at the time and it was and it is really difficult and I think what you said is so accurate actually I feel like he would really like that his money has led me to
是的，我不知道，我想我到时候会不知道该拿自己怎么办。而且，听到你父亲的消息我也很难过，因为无论你多大年纪，这都是一件极其困难的事情。但我当时只有 25 岁，这确实非常困难。我觉得你刚才说的话非常准确，我感觉他会很高兴他的钱让我能够
train in the profession that I've always wanted to so yeah it's a really nice reminder of that when things feel particularly difficult I suppose it really does it really does and I randomly just I can connect to my dad with my weird knobbly wrists like I have strangely knobbly wrists and it was when my dad was unwell in hospital I was like oh I've always looked at your knobbly wrists and mine but I've never quite realized where they've come from but he has them as well and you know just small things like that that you know I've got two children as well and one of them is really sad that he doesn't get to be didn't really get to know grumpy norm and grumpy norm didn't get to know him but i'm still so thankful i got to you know for him to
接受我一直向往的职业培训。所以，当事情感觉特别困难时，这真是一个非常好的提醒。确实如此，确实如此。我偶尔会通过我奇怪的凸起手腕与父亲产生联系。我有奇怪的凸起手腕，当父亲在医院生病时，我心想：“哦，我一直看着你的凸起手腕和我的，但我从未意识到它们来自哪里，但他也有。”你知道，就像这样的小事。我有两个孩子，其中一个真的很伤心，因为他没能认识“暴躁的诺姆”（Grumpy Norm），而“暴躁的诺姆”也没能认识他。但我仍然非常感激，因为在他去世时，他已经是三个孩子的祖父了。我们有一个侄女，现在还有另外两个孩子，所以我们有一个大家庭。我有两个，我哥哥有三个，以防没说清楚。但这一切真的非常非常困难。实际上，现在提到一个我合作过的慈善机构“It's Time”似乎很合适。不知道你是否听说过他们，他们在 Instagram 上，专门支持 25 岁及以下失去父母的人的丧亲、悲伤和失落需求。他们支持那些在童年时期就失去亲人的人。实际上，这在心理上是独特的破坏性，因为在年轻时失去父母，你知道，他们支持的很多人经历的是，即使
be a grandparent to three children at the time that he died because we had it we've got a niece and now we've got two others as well so we've got quite a big family so i've got two and my brother's got three in case it wasn't clear but yeah like it's really really difficult and actually it's feels like it's an appropriate time to mention a charity that I've worked with called It's Time I don't know if you've heard of them but they're on Instagram and they specialize in supporting the bereavement grief and loss needs of people who've lost parents at 25 or below so they support people that have lost you know in pet in child in their own childhood actually is uniquely destabilizing you know being being younger and losing a parent because you know what what a lot of their kind of people that they support experiences even when
他们去上大学，他们可能会回家，但并不是真正的回家。父母可能会遇到新的伴侣，然后搬家或缩小住房规模，这意味着实际上没有他们的容身之处。这是一个非常独特的过程，会让人感到非常疏离。实际上，让我成长最多、在临床上取得进步的事情之一就是失去父亲，但你只有在经历过之后才会知道。我以前不知道我是一个糟糕的临床医生，我不知道我是一个糟糕的人。我不知道。但我其实挺喜欢那种天真的，所以是的，我成长了。是的，我发展了，这是创伤后成长。但我可能宁愿做一个糟糕的人，只要父亲还在，你明白我的意思吗？
they go to university they might be coming home but not really coming home and parent might meet a new partner and then kind of downsize or move that it means that there's not actually any room for them it's a very unique process and can feel very alienating and actually one of the things that's helped me grow up the most and helped me advance clinically probably is losing my dad but you don't know until until you know it I didn't know that I was a know, I didn't know that I was a worse clinician. I didn't know that I was a worse human. I didn't, you know, I didn't know that. But actually, I quite liked the naivety of that, you know, so yes, I've grown. Yes, I've developed it's post dramatic growth. But I probably would rather, I'd rather be a worse human and still
是的，绝对明白。我完全同意你所说的一切。很高兴听到有慈善机构在支持那个年龄段的人，因为虽然我没有专门接触过慈善机构，但我认为特别是在 20 到 25 岁之间，在悲伤等方面的服务存在很大的空白，因为你不再是孩子，也不一定完全是成年人。你处于服务之间的真空地带，而且在那个年纪失去父母并不是常态，所以谢天谢地，你的朋友们也无法真正感同身受。所以我认为有专门针对那个年龄段的慈善机构真是太好了。
have my dad, you know what I mean yeah definitely and I think just agree with everything that you're saying it's so good to hear about charities that are supporting that age group because although I didn't specifically access a charity I think particularly between like 20 and 25 there's such a gap in services for things like grief um because you're not a child and you're not properly necessarily an adult either and you kind of are between services and you know it's not the norm for a parent to die when you're that age so your friends can't really thankfully relate either so I think it's really great that there's charities out there working specifically with that age range.
我认为这真的很好。你不想让他们能够感同身受，对吧？这是一种奇怪的处境。你知道他们并不真正理解。你想要得到支持，但你知道他们不一定能做到，除非他们是非常非常特别的人，否则他们不一定能以你可能需要的方式支持你。
I think that's really great. You don't want them to be able to relate, do you? Like, it's a weird position. You know they don't really get it. And you kind of want to be supported, but you know that they can't necessarily, unless they're very, very special, they can't necessarily support you in the way that you might need.
这是一个非常非常奇怪的时期。但非常感谢你对此如此坦诚。你知道，我们首先是人，其次才是心理学家，但这通常是我们“为什么”的一部分，不是吗？我认为，感谢你的真实、脆弱和诚实。我知道这会引起很多人的共鸣。我们能稍微思考一下什么是健康心理学吗？你能给我们举几个例子，比如营销中所说的“理想客户画像”？我们希望能实现什么样的工作？你提到了服务重组之类的东西，这并不是我从健康角度考虑过的，但如果能了解一下临床工作也会很有用。
It's a very, very strange time. But thank you so much for being so honest about that. You know, we are humans first and we're psychologists second, but it often is part of our why, isn't it? And I think that's, you know, thank you for being so raw, so vulnerable, so honest. And I know this will resonate with so many people. Can we think a little bit about what health psychology is you know what might give us a few examples of kind of ideal client avatars as we say in marketing you know what sort of work could we hope to achieve so you've mentioned kind of service redesign and stuff which isn't really something I'd considered from a from a health angle but be useful to get an overview of kind of clinical work as well yeah and I think it's worth saying that health psychologists often work in so many different settings um that I definitely won't be able to touch on them all but I suppose broadly health psychology as a discipline is relatively young compared to many many others like clinical or counselling
是的，我认为值得一提的是，健康心理学家通常在许多不同的环境中工作，我肯定无法一一提及。但我想广义上讲，健康心理学作为一个学科，与临床或咨询心理学等许多其他人们可能更熟悉的领域相比，相对年轻。但简单来说，健康心理学实际上是研究我们的思想、情绪、行为以及社会因素（如人际关系、文化影响、社会经济地位）如何相互作用以影响我们的身体健康。所以，这一切都是为了理解我们的心理和情绪健康如何影响我们的整体身体健康，反之亦然。并探索人们如何保持健康，为什么会生病，以及他们在生病后如何应对。所以我认为健康心理学很大一部分是首先帮助人们做出更健康的饮食行为选择，无论是戒烟、多运动以管理压力，还是在被诊断出患有癌症等疾病时如何应对，
psychology the the roots that people are perhaps more familiar with but in simple terms health psychology is really the study of how our thoughts our emotions behaviours and our social factors like relationships cultural influences socio-economic status, interact to affect our physical health. So it's all about understanding how our mental and emotional well-being can impact our overall physical well-being and vice versa and exploring how people stay healthy, why they get ill and how they respond once they are unwell as well. So I think quite a big part of health psychology is firstly helping people to make healthier behavioral choices so whether that's stopping smoking, exercising more to manage stress, cope when they are diagnosed with illnesses like
并更广泛地改善他们的整体身心生活质量。例如，在我的临床工作中，在培训期间，我曾与正在接受癌症治疗或处于癌症缓解期的人一起工作，思考他们正在经历什么，特别是在他们的担忧、对康复的想法和感受，以及癌症复发等方面。所以我想这与临床心理学家与某人工作的方式不太一样，但也需要考虑改变某些行为的动机。例如，你可能有一个患过癌症但仍在吸烟，或者可能需要为了健康而减肥的人，
cancer and to improve their overall physical and mental quality of life more broadly. For example in my clinical work whilst on training I've worked with people who are either undergoing cancer treatment or are in remission from cancer and thinking about what is going on for them particularly particularly in terms of their worries, their thoughts and feelings around their recovery and things particularly in cancer about recurrence. So I guess that's not too dissimilar to how a clinical psychologist might work with someone, but also thinking about motivation to change certain behaviors as well so you might have someone who has had cancer but is still engaging with smoking or is perhaps needing to lose some weight for their health
以及他们改变的动机有多强，你如何支持他们从“打算做出改变”转变为“真正去行动”。因为我们知道，意图——你可以拥有世界上最好的意图，但这并不总是会导致做出不同的事情。所以找出原因就是健康心理学家可能会做的事情的一个例子。谢谢，这太有启发性了。它真的让我想起了我的博士研究，那实际上是临床研究，但它可能也很适合健康领域。它可能与健康更相关。它研究的是长期伴侣患有严重中风后，配偶可能会或可能不会做出的健康改变行为。
and how they how motivated they are to change and how you can support them to move beyond intending to make changes to actually going and doing them because we know that intentions you can have the best intentions in the world but it doesn't necessarily always lead to doing something different so working out why that might be is an example of something that health psychologists might do thank you that's so illuminating and it's really reminded me of my doctoral research which was actually it was clinical but it probably also would have fitted nicely within health it's probably probably more relevant to health actually it was looking at the health change behaviors that a spouse might or might not make after their long-term partner has had a serious stroke.
我的想法是，你知道，我们在中风中看到的是可改变和不可改变的风险因素。当发生如此可怕的事情，导致某人丧失能力时，我的感觉是，这怎么能不让你想：“天哪，我要多运动。我要戒烟。我要考虑我的体重指数。”你知道，所有这些事情。从中确实产生了一些创伤后成长。人们确实非常欢迎他们因此而获得的社会支持，但总体发现是，不，他们往往不会关注自己可改变的风险因素。当我们探索这一点时，这一切都是通过扎根理论和一对一访谈完成的，他们说：“我根本没有时间，我没有时间专注于自己。”你知道，最初在医院里有很多时间坐着，那感觉很糟糕，然后他们回家了，然后你意识到那才是真正的旅程。
With my kind of thinking that, you know, what we're looking at in stroke is modifiable and non-modifiable risk factors. And when something so awful happens that somebody is incapacitated, my sense was, how does that not make you go, gosh, well, I'm going to exercise more. I'm going to quit smoking. I'm going to, you know, think about my BMI, you know, all of those things. And there was some post-traumatic growth from that. People really welcomed the social support that they had as a result of that but the general findings were no they don't tend to look at their own modifiable risk factors and when we were exploring that it was all done during grounded theory and was one-to-one interviews and they were like there's
有很多压力，学习如何变得健康。这是一种悲伤，不是吗？这是配偶关系的丧失，然后试图思考你可以保留哪些方面。然后显然是成为某人的照顾者，如果这不棘手，不是吗？我相信你很清楚，拥有自己住房的人通常处于没有资格在英格兰获得任何免费社会护理的境地。所以你可能会处于不得不支持你的丈夫、妻子或长期伴侣进行个人护理的境地，即使你不想那样，他们也不想那样，但否则你将不得不卖掉你的房子，即使那样，你也会因为太富有而无法负担免费的社会护理。这听起来像是“我的钻石鞋太紧了”的情况，但在现实中并非如此，对吧？
just no time for me there's not that time for me to be able to focus on myself you know there's lots of sitting around in hospitals initially and then that feels awful and then they come home and then you realize that that's the real journey um there's so much stress there's learning to be well it's the it's grief isn't it it's the loss of a spousal relationship and then trying to think about what aspects of that you can keep alive and around and then obviously being someone's carer and if there's no tricky isn't it you know I'm sure you're well aware that people who own their homes often they're in a position where they're not eligible to receive any in England certainly receive any free social care and so you might get in a position where you're having to support your husband or your wife or your long-term partner with their personal care even though you wouldn't
不，我认为这只是一个完美的例子，说明了人们在现实中的情况是多么复杂。你知道，被诊断出患有任何严重的疾病本身就是毁灭性的，但如果你的周围有人，这显然会影响到你周围的人。你的财务状况、工作能力、可能出现的耻辱感，你知道，与朋友的关系也会发生变化。我的意思是，它没完没了。
want that they wouldn't want that but otherwise you're going to have to sell your home and even then you'd be too wealthy to be able to afford you know to get the free social care it's it's you know it sounds like a case of my diamond shoes are too tight but it's really not like that in reality is it no I think and that's just like a perfect example of how complex situations are in reality for people um you know receiving a diagnosis of any kind of serious illness on its own it's devastating but then it's obviously impacting the people around you if you're if you have people around you that is um your finances ability to work the stigma that potentially comes up um you know changes in relationships with friends as well I mean there's just it goes on and on and on
当涉及疾病时，影响太大了，这当然是健康心理学经常关注的重点——那些身体不适的人，这理所当然地会对他们的心理健康产生影响。因为如果你不健康，所有这些其他事情都在发生，感觉肯定不会好。所以情绪上感觉不好显然是非常正常的，但这本身也可能成为一个问题。是的，确实如此。我觉得我可以和你聊一整天，和你聊天太容易了，我对你谈论的一切都非常感兴趣。这让你思考过自己的健康、自己的死亡率吗？你知道，我的小儿子，我们前几天在麦当劳参加聚会，他说：“我们能吃些鸡块分享，还有我的食物吗？”我当时说：“不，不，宝贝，我们在这里是为了长久，不仅仅是为了快乐。”因为我确实，而且我和我在一起的朋友说：“我不是，我只是为了快乐。”我说：“这有区别，不是吗？”但对我来说，我通常尽量培养我的男孩们思考他们的饮食，不要非常非常专注于此。你知道，我们一开始就在麦当劳，显然你可能没那么有道德，但你知道，我真的认为，特别是在疫情之后，我刚刚——在我们见面之前，我刚从本周的第二次个人训练课程回来。我在 42 岁时，从未比现在更健康、更强壮。我绝对喜欢这一点。我希望我在年轻时对运动更感兴趣。在我成长过程中，这并不是我家庭生活的重要组成部分。你知道，这是男孩们做的事情，男孩们去踢足球，女孩们可能会打无板篮球，但如果只是偶尔尝试一下。我妈妈总是从零开始做饭，有很多扁豆，有很多全食，你知道，所有这些爵士乐。所以我认为我在很小的时候就有了很好的输入，我从小就学会了做饭，但我一直在随波逐流。我从来没有那么刻意。我从来没有那么有目的性。
there's so many so much of an impact isn't there when there's illness involved which is of course what health psychology is often focused on people who are physically unwell and then that understandably has an impact on their mental health as well because if you're not well and all these other things are happening it's not going to feel great so obviously very normal to feel not great emotionally but that can then become a problem in itself as well yes indeed it can i feel like i could talk to you all day like it's so easy to talk to so i'm so interested in everything you're talking about um has it made you think about your own health your own mortality you know my little boy and we were at a McDonald's party the other day and um he said can we have some nuggets to share as well as my food and I
实际上，只是在过去四年里，我才变得如此。我为自己变得强壮而感到自豪。所以大约一年前，我骑自行车摔断了胳膊，我真是太糟糕了。41 岁时我的第一次骨折。但我真的利用过去这一年思考如何变得更强壮，再次变得更健康，并回到我现在的状态。我绝对做到了。这是一个非常漫长且啰嗦的问题，但这如何影响了你自己的健康之旅，如果问这个问题不太私人的话？我认为这不是我立即想到的，特别是我的兴趣以及我最终进入健康心理学的领域，一直相当集中在特定的领域，比如癌症，还有儿科。
was like no no baby we're here for we're here for a long time not just a good time like you know because I do and and my friend who I was with she was like I'm not I'm just here for a good time like and I'm like there's differences isn't there but for me generally I try to raise my boys to think about their eating like not to be really really hyper focused you know the fact that we're in McDonald's to begin with you could be clearly not that virtuous but um you know I really do I think especially since the pandemic like I've just um just before we met I'm just back from my second personal training session of the week like I've never been fitter stronger or healthier than I am at the age
所以这些事情谢天谢地与我没有直接联系。所以这不是我每天都在想的事情。但我认为在硕士期间，正如我提到的，那是在新冠疫情期间，当时健康和健康行为第一次出现在主流视野中，每个人都在思考，这确实让我开始思考自己作为一个人的情况，以及我周围的人在健身和健康方面的表现。当我这么说时，我想我之前没有联系起来，但在新冠疫情期间，我第一次——作为一个从来不擅长跑步、运动或任何事情的人——决定为铁人三项进行训练。所以我猜在无意中，它确实影响了我，让我思考我的动机。而且我认为对于许多年轻女性来说——这本身可能就是一个完整的话题，留待以后讨论——许多年轻女性，当然在我的朋友中，我们经常讨论社会对女性在体重和身体形象方面的期望，以及在特定时代成长，某种饮食文化，以及必须看起来像某种样子，这在很多我们这一代人中根深蒂固。思考我为铁人三项这样的赛事进行训练的动机是很有趣的，从体重和外表转向能力，变得强壮，变得普遍健康，而不是为了形象而运动。所以我认为这绝对是出现的事情，也是我通过健康心理学更关注的事情。绝对是。当你说话时，我脑海中浮现的词是“充满活力”。我想变得充满活力地健康，我想变得强壮。这可能并不意味着我能达到的最瘦的状态，这不是重点，重点是知道我的身体有能力，并且我能够做我想做的所有事情。
of 42 and I absolutely love that I wish I'd been more interested in exercise when I was younger like it wasn't really a big part of my family growing up you know it's something that boys did really boys went to football and girls might do netball but if you know just a dabble here and there and my mum's always cooked from scratch or there's lots of lentils you know lots of kind of whole foods and you know all of that jazz but so I think I had kind of good good kind of input at an early age and I learned to cook from an early age, but I was coasting. I was never that intentional. I was never that purposeful.
42岁了，我非常喜欢这一点。我真希望自己年轻时对运动更感兴趣。在我成长的过程中，运动并不是家庭生活的重要组成部分。你知道的，那是男孩子做的事，男孩子去踢足球，女孩子可能会打无板篮球，但也只是偶尔玩玩。我妈妈总是自己做饭，用很多扁豆，很多全天然食品之类的。所以我认为我在很小的时候就有了很好的饮食基础，也学会了做饭，但我一直处于一种随波逐流的状态，从来没有那么刻意，也从来没有那么有目标。
And really, it's only over the last four years that I have become so. And I'm so proud that I am strong. So almost a year ago, I broke my arm falling off my bike and I'm just rubbish. My first break at the age of 41, I was then. But I really used this last year to think about getting stronger getting healthier again and getting back to where I am and I'm absolutely there and very long warbled question but how has this impacted on your own health journey if that's not too personal a question to ask I think it's not something that I immediately thought of, particularly my sort of interests and where I've ended up in health psychology have been quite focused on specific areas like cancer, on pediatrics as well.
事实上，直到过去四年我才变得如此。我为自己变得强壮而感到自豪。大约一年前，我骑自行车摔断了胳膊，我真是太糟糕了。那是我41岁时的第一次骨折。但我确实利用过去这一年思考如何变得更强壮、更健康，并恢复到现在的状态，我绝对做到了。这是一个很长且啰嗦的问题，但如果这个问题不太私人的话，我想问这对你自己的健康之旅有什么影响？我想我并没有立刻想到这一点，尤其是我的兴趣以及我最终从事的健康心理学领域，一直相当专注于特定的领域，比如癌症，还有儿科。
So things that aren't directly linked to me, thankfully. So it's not something that's in my mind on a day to day basis. But I suppose definitely within the masters that was, as I mentioned, during COVID, when health and health behavior was, for the first time ever, probably in the mainstream, something that everyone was thinking about, it definitely made me think about myself as a person and people around me in terms of our fitness and health and um as I'm saying this I think I hadn't linked it before but during Covid I for the first time ever having not been someone that was ever good at running or sport or anything decided to train for triathlon so I guess inadvertently it did influence me and think about my motivations and um I think for lots of young women and this is probably a whole topic in itself
所以这些事情谢天谢地与我没有直接联系。因此，这不是我每天都会想到的事情。但我认为，在攻读硕士学位期间，正如我提到的，那是在新冠疫情期间，当时健康和健康行为第一次成为主流，每个人都在思考这些问题，这确实让我开始从个人角度思考自己以及周围人的体能和健康状况。嗯，当我这么说的时候，我想我之前并没有把它们联系起来，但在新冠疫情期间，我第一次决定训练参加铁人三项，尽管我以前从不擅长跑步、运动或任何其他项目。所以我想，这在无意中确实影响了我，让我思考自己的动机。嗯，我认为对于许多年轻女性来说，这本身就是一个完整的话题，
for another another day but um a lot of young women and certainly amongst my friends we have conversations about societal expectations on women around weight and body image and growing up in a certain era and sort of diet culture and having to look a certain way being quite ingrained in a lot of us it was interesting to think about my motivations and training for an event like a triathlon, moving away from things like weight and how you look to ability, being strong and being generally fit and well rather than so exercising for health rather than for image. So I think that's definitely something that came up and is something that is more on my radar, definitely through health psychology. Absolutely. And the word for me, that is conjured up when you're speaking is, is vibrant, like, I want to be vibrantly healthy, I want to be strong. And that might not mean that I'm the skinniest I could ever be like it's not about that it's about knowing that my body is capable and you know is I'm able to do all the things I want
留待改天再谈。嗯，很多年轻女性，当然包括我的朋友们，我们经常讨论社会对女性在体重和身体形象方面的期望。在特定的时代成长，加上节食文化，以及必须保持某种外表的观念，在很多人的心中根深蒂固。思考我训练参加铁人三项这类赛事的动机是很有趣的，我开始从关注体重和外表转向关注能力，变得强壮，保持整体的健康和良好状态，而不是为了外表而锻炼。所以我认为这绝对是我意识到的事情，也绝对是通过健康心理学让我更加关注的事情。绝对是这样。你说话时让我联想到的词是“充满活力”，我想变得充满活力地健康，我想变得强壮。这可能并不意味着我要达到我所能达到的最瘦的状态，这不是重点，重点是知道我的身体是有能力的，我知道我能够做我想做的所有事情。
to do like pick up my children even though one of them's 10 but insist on being carried sometimes like you know I want to be like I said I want to be here for for a long time not just a good time and once you know absolutely you've been speaking about locus of control you know often a lot of the work that you're doing sounds like it's with people who haven't had locus control for their illness but actually I would love the idea that if I face an untimely end that my body's in such a great condition that I'm able to be a really brilliant organ donor you know so I'm not just looking after myself now I'm looking after hopefully you know future people if I have an untimely end I don't want that to happen you know let's not let's not let that come to fruition but you know I am here
比如去接我的孩子们，尽管其中一个已经10岁了，但有时还是坚持要我抱。你知道，就像我说的那样，我想长久地陪伴在这里，而不仅仅是享受当下的快乐。既然你提到了控制点，你所做的工作听起来很多都是针对那些对自己的疾病缺乏控制感的人。但实际上，我非常喜欢这样一个想法：如果我遭遇了不幸，我的身体状况依然保持得很好，以至于我能成为一名非常出色的器官捐赠者。所以，我不仅是为了现在的自己而照顾身体，也是为了未来的人们。如果我遭遇不幸，我不希望发生这种情况，我们不要让它发生，但你知道，我在这里
to enrich my own world other people to be here for my family but you know I'm looking after myself yeah and I think so much is about that prevention work as well so you're hopefully reducing your likelihood of developing preventable illnesses and if you are in a situation of being diagnosed with something um that your body is fit and well enough to cope with that illness in itself but also the treatment as well so I think it definitely puts you into a different perspective thinking about health and things that you can do behaviorally to try and improve your health outcomes as well yeah absolutely even you know when I broke my arms it was this it was this one my left arm it's all back because I can't see what you're watching here but I could only get it to like
是为了丰富我自己的世界，为了陪伴我的家人，但我确实在照顾自己。我认为预防工作也非常重要，希望你能降低患上可预防疾病的可能性。如果你不幸被诊断出某种疾病，你的身体足够健康，不仅能应对疾病本身，也能应对治疗。所以我认为，这确实让你从不同的角度思考健康，以及你可以通过行为来改善健康结果。是的，绝对是这样。甚至当我摔断手臂时，是左臂，现在都恢复了，因为我看不见你在看什么，但我当时只能把它抬到
here to begin with because what what we often don't really realize is even within two days of not using our bodies as we usually would do our tendons all shrink and contract don't they and our muscles start to waste around way because we're conserving that energy the body and so my physio told me at the time the body goes oh we're not using that let's not waste that let's save that let's kind of almost reabsorb that so the body is trying to be really helpful and smart but actually means that it takes so much more to stretch those tendons to stretch that body again once you have lost that fitness so to begin with I'm not wearing the best dress for it I probably can't demonstrate it very
这里。起初，我们往往没有意识到，即使仅仅两天不按正常方式使用身体，我们的肌腱就会萎缩和收缩，肌肉也会因为身体在节能而开始萎缩。我的理疗师当时告诉我，身体会觉得‘我们不用那个部位，那就别浪费能量了，把它存起来，几乎要重新吸收掉’。所以身体是在试图提供帮助和变得聪明，但实际上这意味着一旦你失去了那种健康状态，就需要付出更多的努力来拉伸肌腱，重新拉伸身体。所以起初，我穿的衣服不太适合，我可能无法很好地演示
well um and this is terrible if you're listening to it but if you're watching on YouTube it's great um you know I couldn't get it beyond there but now I can fully touch my shoulder again which actually when I first started the physio she didn't think I would necessarily get to based on where I was but I wasn't prepared so I didn't get NHS physio I wasn't prepared to settle for an arm that didn't bend so thankfully I was in a position where I was able to pay for some private physio but it's really empowering people to know that even though you might not you know have the best outcomes you can do something you can take action to to make it different hopefully yeah and you mentioned locus of control and I'm well aware this is very like geeky thing to say but locus of control and health locus of control definitely
嗯，如果你只是在听音频，这听起来很糟糕，但如果你在YouTube上看视频，那就很棒了。你知道，我之前只能抬到那个位置，但现在我可以完全触碰到我的肩膀了。实际上，当我刚开始理疗时，她根据我当时的情况，并不认为我一定能做到。但我没有准备好，我没有接受NHS的理疗，我不打算接受一只无法弯曲的手臂。谢天谢地，我有能力支付一些私人理疗费用。这确实赋予了人们力量，让他们知道即使你可能没有得到最好的结果，你也可以采取行动，做出改变。是的，你提到了控制点，我很清楚这听起来很书呆子气，但健康控制点绝对是
two of the models that I like a lot and draw on a lot and I think often when it comes to health people feel quite powerless people feel like they haven't got much say in what their what's happening to them what their treatment is and I suppose in the past there was much more of a sort of a medical model of I'm a doctor I'm a professional and I'm going to do to you what I think is best and you will just do it whereas now there's much more of a dialogue of what do you think what would be best for you taking into account a person as a whole and giving them some of that control which ultimately is going to make you feel psychologically more able to cope and hopefully lead to better outcomes as well so I think control is such a huge thing in so many aspects of life and health as well it really is and as as you spoke I was
我非常喜欢并经常引用的两个模型。我认为当涉及到健康时，人们往往感到相当无力，觉得对自己身上发生的事情、治疗方案没有什么发言权。我想在过去，更多的是一种医疗模式，即‘我是医生，我是专业人士，我会对你做我认为最好的事情，你照做就行了’。而现在，更多的是一种对话，询问‘你觉得呢？什么对你最有利？’，将人作为一个整体来考虑，并赋予他们一定的控制权。这最终会让你在心理上感觉更有能力应对，并有望带来更好的结果。所以我认为控制权在生活的方方面面以及健康方面都是一件大事。确实如此，正如你所说，我当时
thinking about when I first heard of the term locus of control and it was during my a-level psychology and I also heard about loftus and you know the bystander effect and all of that jazz which brings us nicely into the fact that you also do psychology tutoring as well don't you tell our audience so we do actually have A-level students listening we have undergraduate students listening we sometimes have GCSE psychology students listening I know it's not super common but we really have got a wide range of people. We also have qualified psychologists who listen too. But something that's cropped up with me working with young people is that they believe that accessing a tutor is cheating. And I've sort of
在想我第一次听到‘控制点’这个词的时候，那是在我的A-level心理学课程中。我还听说了洛夫特斯（Loftus）和旁观者效应等等。这很好地引出了一个事实，那就是你也做心理学辅导，对吧？告诉我们的听众，我们确实有A-level学生在听，有本科生在听，有时还有GCSE心理学学生在听。我知道这不太常见，但我们确实有广泛的受众。我们也有合格的心理学家在听。但我在与年轻人工作时发现，他们认为找导师辅导是作弊。我一直
always tried to say, what about the Olympic athletes who have coaches? Is that cheating too? And they're like, no. But how can people give themselves permission to optimize their performance by you know and access appropriate tutoring and why is that important yeah and I think it's really important to think about because a lot of people as you say either don't know that it is an option to have a tutor alongside wherever it is that you're learning your course, whether it's school or college or somewhere else. But also have lots of different ideas about whether it's allowed, whether it's giving you more of an advantage than it should, etc, etc. So I think firstly to say, loads of people have tutoring. And I think it's important to say it's not always accessible to everyone
试图说，那些有教练的奥运选手呢？那也是作弊吗？他们会说，不。但人们如何才能给自己许可去优化自己的表现，通过获取适当的辅导，为什么这很重要？我认为这非常值得思考，因为正如你所说，很多人要么不知道在学习课程（无论是学校、学院还是其他地方）的同时还可以找导师，要么对这是否被允许、是否给了你不应有的优势等有很多不同的想法。所以首先我想说，很多人都有辅导。而且我认为重要的是要说，这并不总是对每个人都可及的，
because it's not free but there is free resources out there that are you know accessible to everyone but one-to-one tutoring like I offer through a platform called First Tutors what happens is people usually get in touch with me I say most often they're A-level students, but sometimes it's undergraduate or even master students as well. And sometimes that's because people are struggling with a very specific aspect of their course, whether that's statistics, that's a common one, or whether they're just struggling with the subject as a whole and want to give themselves some more time to improve their understanding have the chance to ask questions that there may be no time for at school or maybe you feel you know quite shy about asking questions in front of all
因为它不是免费的，但确实有免费资源可供所有人使用。但我通过一个叫First Tutors的平台提供的一对一辅导，通常是人们联系我。我说最常见的是A-level学生，但有时也有本科生甚至硕士生。有时是因为人们在课程的某个特定方面遇到困难，比如统计学（这是一个常见的问题），或者他们只是在整个学科上感到吃力，想要给自己更多的时间来提高理解力，有机会问那些在学校里可能没时间问的问题，或者你可能在所有人面前问问题会感到害羞。
your peers lots of different reasons so tutoring and the chance to spend an hour one-to-one with someone who hopefully knows a bit about the subject can be really helpful for people. And I was just tutoring someone this morning who I've worked with throughout the entirety of her A-level. And that's not to say that she was struggling at all. I think quite the opposite. She's actually very able and is looking to do the best she possibly can so uses the sessions to work on not so much understanding the concepts but developing her critical evaluation of psychological concepts whereas I've had people I tutor in the past who really sometimes regret choosing
有很多不同的原因，所以辅导以及有机会与一个可能对该学科有所了解的人进行一小时的一对一交流，对人们非常有帮助。我今天早上刚辅导了一个学生，我在她整个A-level期间都和她一起工作。这并不是说她遇到了困难，恰恰相反。她实际上非常有能力，并且希望尽可能做到最好，所以她利用这些课程不是为了理解概念，而是为了发展她对心理学概念的批判性评估。而我过去辅导过的人，有时真的很后悔选择
psychology as a subject and feel like they don't have the understanding of just sort of key concepts and having that time and space to work through those at their own pace can just help them to sometimes have a real light bulb moment and think oh actually I do get it and I will be able to sit my exam so I think lots of people have it and it's totally okay to do so yeah I wish I'd had it and actually the more and more I learn about myself as an adult and the more and more I learn about neurodiversity I think I probably do fulfill the diagnostic criteria for ADHD. And when it got to the A levels, I actually really missed that accountability of the teachers making you do the work. Once it was up to me to put that accountability in place, I wasn't very good at it.
心理学作为一门学科，觉得他们对关键概念缺乏理解。有时间和空间按照自己的节奏去钻研这些概念，可以帮助他们有时产生真正的顿悟，觉得‘哦，其实我懂了，我能参加考试了’。所以我认为很多人都有辅导，这样做完全没问题。是的，我希望我当时也有辅导。实际上，随着我作为成年人对自己了解得越来越多，随着我对神经多样性了解得越来越多，我想我可能确实符合ADHD的诊断标准。当到了A-level考试时，我真的很怀念老师督促你完成作业的那种责任感。一旦需要我自己来承担这种责任，我就做得不太好。
The unstructured time I found really difficult to manage manage and I would often be just lounging around or having a nap in the common room like that's not that useful but also because I was working on a Saturday and a Sunday and sometimes a Tuesday after work at Boots the Chemist and also I had a boyfriend and I wanted to see my friends I think I had just too much on my plate and so I was probably very tired but I could have done with the time that I was studying to be more accountable more focused and more productive I only got a C at A level I believe I was capable of a much higher grade but I just feel like I wasn't quite getting to the levels that you need to be able to get to and I got a low 2.1 at university for very much the same reasons I feel like I was capable of much more but I needed some help and some support to be more
我发现非结构化的时间真的很难管理，我经常在公共休息室闲逛或打盹，这没什么用。而且因为我周六、周日以及有时周二下班后在Boots药房工作，我还有一个男朋友，我想见我的朋友，我觉得我手头的事情太多了，所以我可能非常累。但我本可以利用学习的时间来让自己更有责任感、更专注、更高效。我的A-level只得了C，我相信我有能力获得更高的成绩，但我只是觉得我没有达到你需要达到的水平。我在大学里也只拿到了一个低二等一学位，原因非常相似。我觉得我有能力做得更多，但我需要一些帮助和支持来变得
structured yeah and I think that is such a valid point as well because it's not just about the subject itself let alone the fact that most people are studying more than one a level so it's not just the psychology that they need to think about it's what's going on the rest of the time in your life you know when you're 16 17 18 other things are usually going on um both externally but both but also in terms of your inner thoughts and how you feel about yourself and the world and what you've got to do so it's really hard to balance that and I wanted to just touch on what you said about sort of get what grades you got at both A level and undergraduate I think people tend to think well I'm not getting an A star so I can't do psychology and I definitely can't be a psychologist and that's definitely not the case whilst I got an A at psychology I didn't get an A in any other A level I missed my university offers was absolutely devastated thought it was the end of the world and I still I'm still in
更有条理。是的，我认为这是一个非常有效的观点，因为这不仅仅是关于学科本身，更不用说大多数人学习的不仅仅是一门A-level课程。所以他们不仅要考虑心理学，还要考虑生活中其他时间发生的事情。你知道，当你16、17、18岁时，通常还有其他事情发生，既有外部的，也有关于你内心想法、你对自己和世界的感受以及你必须要做的事情。所以平衡这些真的很难。我想谈谈你提到的关于在A-level和本科阶段获得的成绩。我认为人们倾向于认为‘我拿不到A*，所以我不能学心理学，我肯定不能成为心理学家’，这绝对不是事实。虽然我在心理学上拿了A，但我其他任何A-level科目都没有拿A。我错过了大学录取通知，当时彻底崩溃了，以为世界末日到了。我仍然
touch with my A level psychology teacher today and every year on results day, she texts me and says, I've never, never seen anyone so devastated as you were. I was in clearing. I went to university through clearing and then got a first class degree. So it doesn't matter if things don't always go to plan. You obviously need to work hard throughout but you don't always need to be getting the top grades everywhere to be a good psychologist in the end yeah I hear you and you know I think I'm a reasonable psychologist and I still didn't
和我的A-level心理学老师保持着联系，每年成绩公布那天，她都会给我发短信说：‘我从来没见过像你当时那样崩溃的人。’ 我当时通过补录（Clearing）进入了大学，后来获得了一等学位。所以，事情不总是按计划进行也没关系。你显然需要在整个过程中努力工作，但你并不总是需要在各方面都获得最高分才能最终成为一名优秀的心理学家。是的，我明白你的意思。你知道，我认为我是一名合格的心理学家，但我当时并没有
get the best grades I did all right at GCSEs but I think it was that accountability um I think I was so excited by secondary school I worked really hard for year seven year eight and year nine and then I was a bit bored of it ready for a new challenge so I probably still didn't work as hard in my GCSEs as actually I would have done if I'd sat them in year seven I'm better then um but yeah thank you so much for your time today. I felt like this has been a really nourishing, beautiful, wholesome exploration of health psychology and existential matters too. Have you got any advice for people if they need to avoid burnout on the way to on the way to psychology or even within psychology tough question and I think something that
拿到最好的成绩。我在GCSE考试中表现还可以，但我认为那是责任感的问题。我觉得我在中学时太兴奋了，七年级、八年级和九年级工作非常努力，然后我就有点厌倦了，准备迎接新的挑战。所以我可能在GCSE考试中并没有像我在七年级时那样努力。我那时表现更好。但非常感谢你今天抽出时间。我觉得这是一次对健康心理学和存在主义问题的非常有益、美好且健康的探索。对于那些在通往心理学道路上，甚至在心理学领域内需要避免倦怠的人，你有什么建议吗？这是一个棘手的问题，我认为有些事情
personally I've definitely struggled with at times I think I don't know what you think but people who are aspiring to be or are psychologists tend to be quite hard-working quite keen to be supportive of other people giving and think if you don't look after yourself within that that can lead you into all sorts of issues particularly if part of your job involves supporting people through really challenging emotional difficulties it can be hard to remember to look after yourself within that so I suppose the first thing is being aware of that and if you're you do have tendency to push yourself quite hard um whatever stage you're at whether it's a level or or post qualified um I'd always say again accessibility is a problem but having
我个人有时确实在挣扎。我想不知道你怎么看，但那些渴望成为或已经是心理学家的人往往非常努力，非常热衷于支持他人，乐于奉献。如果你在其中不照顾好自己，那可能会导致各种问题。特别是如果你的工作的一部分涉及支持人们度过非常具有挑战性的情绪困难，那么在其中记住照顾好自己可能会很困难。所以我认为第一件事是意识到这一点。如果你确实有过度逼迫自己的倾向，无论你处于什么阶段，是A-level还是获得资格后，我总是会说，虽然可及性是一个问题，但拥有
your own therapy has been really or is really important for me in understanding myself why I might react in certain ways and how to look after myself but also just making time for yourself as well and that sounds like a really cliche piece of advice but I think I'm always tempted to do everything now and get everything done now. And unless something is imminently urgent or risky, I think it can wait for five minutes, an hour or until tomorrow, and it's not going to go anywhere. So I suppose being aware of yourself, knowing what helps you and just taking a bit of time to stop and think before you keep rushing to do things which I definitely still have to remind myself of absolutely such beautiful advice and if people want to connect with you or follow you where's the best place for them to do that
你自己的治疗师真的非常重要，这对我理解自己为什么会以某种方式反应以及如何照顾自己很有帮助。但也只是为自己留出时间。这听起来像是一个非常陈词滥调的建议，但我认为我总是想现在就做完所有事情。除非某件事迫在眉睫或有风险，否则我认为它可以等五分钟、一小时或等到明天，它不会跑掉。所以我认为要了解自己，知道什么对你有帮助，在继续匆忙做事之前花点时间停下来思考一下，这一点我确实仍然需要提醒自己。绝对是，非常美好的建议。如果人们想与你联系或关注你，最好的方式是什么？
you mentioned the place where you do tutoring through feel free to mention more about how people can find you if they're like I want Nicola to be my tutor give yourself a little advert that's absolutely fine so tutoring wise first first tutors if you just give that a google and put Nicola O'Donnell in you'll find me so in six weeks time I will all being well qualify as a health psychologist had my viva invitation yesterday um so you can find me on linkedin uh just nicola o'donnell I also do a lot on twitter and on instagram I post a lot about being a health psychologist the training routes um and all sorts of what a health psychologist actually does. Thank you so much. I've absolutely adored speaking with you today.
你提到了你进行辅导的地方，如果人们想找你做导师，请随意多介绍一下，给自己做一个小广告，这完全没问题。关于辅导，First Tutors，如果你在谷歌上搜索一下，加上Nicola O'Donnell，你就能找到我。六周后，如果一切顺利，我将获得健康心理学家的资格，昨天收到了论文答辩邀请。所以你可以在LinkedIn上找到我，就是Nicola O'Donnell。我也经常在Twitter和Instagram上发布关于作为一名健康心理学家的工作、培训途径以及健康心理学家实际上做什么的内容。非常感谢。我非常喜欢今天与你的交谈。
And I feel like there's so many shared interests that it's felt, yeah, really, I don't know, this just really resonated with me. And it's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you. Wishing you the very best of luck for your viva. There is an episode on the podcast series about how to prepare optimally for your viva. I'm sure you probably know it all already. I listened it was very helpful oh good thank you and obviously anyone
我觉得我们有这么多共同的兴趣，感觉，是的，真的，我不知道，这真的引起了我的共鸣。与你交谈绝对是一种荣幸。祝你在论文答辩中一切顺利。播客系列中有一集关于如何为论文答辩做好最佳准备。我相信你可能已经都知道了。我听了，非常有帮助。哦，太好了，谢谢。显然，任何
listening or watching please do um take a listen um thank you so much for your time nicola thank you for having me it's been really nice to speak to you honestly i just love that like i feel i feel warm i feel connected you know I know that Nicola and I had a lot in common some similar overlaps but I just I hope that you feel that way about this episode as well if you do please take a moment to rate the podcast to review the podcast and to subscribe to the podcast on whatever platform you are listening to or watching it on because it helps us to reach a wider audience and it's the single most valuable thing that you can do for any podcast that you enjoy. If you like the way that I think, the way that I talk
正在收听或观看的人，请务必听一听。非常感谢你抽出时间，Nicola。谢谢你邀请我，和你交谈真的非常愉快。老实说，我真的很喜欢这样，我感到温暖，感到连接。我知道Nicola和我有很多共同点，有一些相似的重叠，但我只是希望你对这一集也有同样的感觉。如果你有这种感觉，请花点时间在任何你收听或观看的平台上为播客评分、评论和订阅，因为它能帮助我们接触到更广泛的受众，这是你能为你喜欢的任何播客做的最有价值的事情。如果你喜欢我的思考方式、我的说话方式，
and you think that I might be able to help you meet some of your future or current career goals, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And of course, remember all of those wonderful back issues of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you so much for being part of my world come and let me know what you think to this episode by connecting on socials i am dr marianne trent absolutely everywhere and come and let me know what you think to this episode in my free facebook group the aspiring psychologist community you can listen to the next episode from 10 a.m on saturdays on youtube and from 6am on Mondays as an MP3. Thank you so much,
并且你认为我可能能够帮助你实现一些未来或当前的职业目标，请务必查看《Aspiring Psychologist Collective》一书、《Clinical Psychologist Collective》一书以及《Aspiring Psychologist》会员资格。当然，别忘了《Aspiring Psychologist》播客的所有精彩往期节目。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。通过社交媒体联系我，让我知道你对这一集的看法。我是Marianne Trent博士，在所有平台上都能找到我。在我的免费Facebook群组‘Aspiring Psychologist Community’中告诉我你对这一集的看法。你可以在周六上午10点在YouTube上收听下一集，或者在周一上午6点作为MP3收听。非常感谢，
stay kind to yourself and I will see you very soon. With this podcast, I feel sad to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself
对自己好一点，我们很快就会再见。通过这个播客，我感到很难过，因为你即将获得资格。这是Marianne Trent博士的《Aspiring Psychologist Podcast》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你
at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。